[Music]
[Music]
shadow of war is an epic third-person
open-world action RPG and the sequel to
the award-winning shadow of Mordor this
walkthrough takes place many hours into
the game where we will show you one
example of the epic personal stories
created to the next generation of the
revolutionary nemesis systems
save middle-earth we will be journeying
deep behind enemy lines and using the
new ring of power Georgian army and
conquer model from within on the world
map we see the many regions we can
conquer every one of these regions at
the distinct environment with unique
enemies and Ally including overlords war
chief captain followers fortresses
strongholds mission and met today we're
going to attack and conquer the mountain
valley of Sarah go and take it from
sauron's Over Law Board hakan the dragon
world
let's launch the assault
not only our enemies and the world that
make the Nemesis system unique it also
are following robbed you the iron map
have armored cavalry that can charge to
the flames of artillery fire the
demolisher is a living battering ram
into power to smash enemy defenses but
our followers at our side we must first
face the stormbringer for you and you
left me to die I was me for he have a
history and personal grudge against us
he used to be part of our army before he
betrayed her and joined the dark lord he
also carries a dark curse which prevents
us from using the power of the new range
charge into the flames of your reckoning
the Overlord has deployed multiple sport
defenses including siege beef and flame
Archer
No
[Applause]
our first objective will be to break
through the main gate
good boy
[Music]
you feel it Jochi me you can power of
the dark
with the stormbringer defeated we've
broken the curse and can unleash our
power as the demolisher breaches the
gates allowing our army to storm the
fort
there are many ways to conquer a horse
from open combat self and infiltration
Oh
we've infiltrated a spy within the enemy
rank
Jedi has placed explosives allowing us
to sabotage the walls and outflank the
defender
did you really think you could kill me
[Applause]
the sky is also able to help clear the
way like sniping enemies in shadow of
Mordor the Nemesis system created
memorable stories of bloodshed and
revenge in shadow of war your followers
can create entirely new stories of
loyalty betrayal rivalry and even
friendship thanks Dada short we've
expanded the RPG systems and shadow of
war enormously defeating stormbringer
allows us to collect this epic armor of
Rohan and equip it
reigns am I kidding good storm bringer
bye
I
Wow
mounting Armored Cavalry allows us to
ride through these flames on home
[Music]
releasing and dominating the Drake let's
have turned the overlords defenses
against
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you've terrified the flame of war now
bend him to your will the Ring of Power
allows us to dominate the minds of our
enemies I am you're telling them to join
our growing army now with the power of
the new ring and the help of our
followers we defeated to watching
we can face our ultimate nemesis we love
sport the Dragon Lord Himself time take
what is ours with the Nemesis system
every overlord faced by every player
will be unique to their world and the
throne room itself has been customized
by the Overlord as in personal combat
arena it's the Lord of Mordor himself
the brief you've made a right mess punch
I are you slain I Drake's dead so much
I know he'll or two about me
annual it's gone
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
let me show you how
it's my
[Music]
with the overlord defeated thoughts are
aghast and this region of Moodle are
ours
[Music]
conquering the region rewards us with
experience loop new followers and
resources it also creates a personal
base from which we train our forces
increase our power and upgrade our
defenses against Iran's counter-attacks
let's return to the army screen where we
can review our enemies and command our
followers we need to select one to
become the new overlord so he can spread
his influence throughout the region
creating an entirely original nemesis
portrait this war chief is a necromancer
he will shroud the force in sorcery to
confuse and terrify tackle this war
chief is a beast master he will allow
turn the creatures of Mordor against our
enemies but we're going to promote Raju
the war chief who charged through that
artillery assault and helped us bring
down autók on the Dragon Lord as a
Marauder he can loot and pillage the
region for
with our new overlord in place we can
upgrade the fortress increasing its
defenses and enlarging the size and
power of our armed
the Nemesis system means that every
element of this mission was dynamic and
unique no two players of the game will
experience the same story this is one
step in our conquest of mortal one small
example the minions of unique stories
players will create a middle earth
shadow of war
[Music]
[Music]
all the bright Lord
you
criminal
you